[Music]
they need to know we're still here this
is the Teen Titans can anyone hear us we
think we found a way back that looks
like us but better
these Teen Titans were about character
development drama and heart I used to be
so much cooler I want to watch
[Music]
all
whoa
[Music]
what that's how it is and there is no
sixth season to resolve the plots
hanging from the cliffs you ended that
show you monster
hey everybody is Charlie there like us
only better so apparently a Teen Titans
season six is a real thing if you saw
Teen Titans go in the theater this
weekend this is the mid-credits sequence
so if you don't know what's going on the
animation suddenly changes from
traditional Teen Titans go to the
original Teen Titans animated series and
they say we found a way to come back so
it sounds like they're pulling a Clone
Wars and they're actually gonna do a
season six somewhere so let's break it
down if you're brand new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos this is just the beginning we
also have Young Justice season 3 coming
up soon and there's a new round of that
flash ring giveaway all you have to do
to enter that is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on the video so quick
recap on the history of the Teen Titans
animated series before it became T
Titans go they did five seasons they've
been primarily using season 5 to
introduce the Doom Patrol and deal with
beast boys origins he used to be called
changeling when he first became a
superhero character he joined the Doom
Patrol they had all kinds of crazy
adventures eventually he aged up he
matured he joined the Teen Titans and
became the beast boy that you know today
but every once in a while they would
interact with the Doom Patrol because
they'd be off having their crazy
adventures to really became a big
popularity thing like Grant Morrison has
this awesome Doom Patrol run that
they're using to do a live-action Doom
Patrol series but they were never quite
as popular as Teen Titans became so
that's just where Beast Boy stayed for a
long time so they have a season 5 but
they end on a cliffhanger and supposedly
there was a plan season 6 but instead of
doing that they canceled that show used
all the same actors to do the same
characters and just rebooted everything
into Teen Titans go so everybody was
really surprised like this was a popular
show everybody liked it what was going
on why would you cancel a popular show
there were a lot of theories that went
around mainly that even though they were
finding an audience
it wasn't the audience the Cartoon
Network wanted to market to so they
traditionally program for very young
audiences remember how we're getting
Young Justice Season 3 on the
see streaming service next year that was
also a really good show that Cartoon
Network cancelled the reason why it's
coming back is because it was such a
good show but it had a hard time finding
the right audience because of the
network that was on Hamas no fuss you
tested positive for the meta-gene
princess Tara would likely have tested
positive as well which explains why she
was taken
something daring must be done if I have
to save markovia meta-gene activated
let's see what we've got
so when Cartoon Network has a popular
show but it's not popular with the
little kids that they're marketing
towards they usually get rid of it it's
a really common problem with child
driven Network
[Music]
that is some serious hero work Titans
Aqualad
we came here to clean up your mess but
it looks like you have everything under
control perhaps you can admit you
misjudged us if there's a show that's
really popular and goes on for a long
time the audience ages out of the
marketing demo that they want to hit so
suddenly you're not the audience that
they want to market to that you were a
couple years ago there were rumors the
Cartoon Network felt like that younger
audience they were trying to hit wasn't
able to follow the heavily serialized
storylines in the kids did not like the
anime look of the series the original
series is very heavily inspired by anime
the new series much simpler animation
style there was a joke that an animator
on Castlevania made about the difference
between one of their characters faces
then all of Steven universe show this
program for young children so I think
it's pretty self-explanatory why they
rebooted Teen Titans into Teen Titans go
is that they just wanted to simplify
everything for a much younger audience
which kind of sucks but that's why
Cartoon Network has Adult Swim for shows
like Rick and Morty that want to play to
the adult audience not for young
children they have not said anything
about where this apparent season six is
going to drop so even though Warner
Brothers animation made this movie and
Warner Brothers released it Cartoon
Network I think technically owns that
Teen Titans series so if they did a
season six they would get first crack at
it but I think a good example to look at
is Clone Wars so Disney is bringing back
Clone Wars again Clone Wars save it was
a big thing during comic-con last week
but they're gonna drop that on Disney's
new streaming service next year when it
launches so they might be doing the same
thing with Teen Titans season 6
they might just drop it on this new DC
streaming service next year but just
because they dropped this teaser doesn't
mean that they've started animation like
nobody has said anything official about
it
what'll probably happen is is after
everybody goes to the movies this
weekend sees this and starts talking
about it then they'll make an official
announcement like oh yeah you saw that
teaser well this is what our plans are
for season six but all signs point to
that happening sometime next year I
don't think they would have dropped this
teaser now if they hadn't planned on
doing that in the relative near future
in the DC streaming service they're
launching later this month is starved
for content they need all the new shows
they can get so it just seems like a
real easy slam-dunk for them to drop
Teen Titans season six but we'll find
out more about that role soon post all
your reactions in the comments below you
may have heard this morning the Disney
and Fox approved the merger meaning the
x-men are that much closer to crossing
over with the Avengers I'll do a video
about that later today and what I think
some of their early plans for those
characters are because everything is
pointing towards them getting that done
by next year there's still a couple
hurdles they have to jump through but
I'll explain when I post that video but
things are looking really good right now
so click here to rewatch The Young
Justice season 3 trailer and click here
for brand new Avengers 4 thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]